bonsoir henri sterdyniak merci d'être
avec nous sur arte france d'abord le
bilan que vous faites sur le plan des
réformes pour emmanuel macron cette
année heureusement la crise sanitaire
est venu paralyser un certain nombre de
réformes d'abord comme on va le dire la
réforme des retraites ensuite la réforme
de l'assurance chômage le gouvernement a
eu d'autres préoccupations et puis
également il faut pas l'oublier
hong hao devait avoir une grande réforme
du des minima sociaux avec un revenu
universel d'activités tout ça a été
balayée par la préoccupation centrale
qui était celle de de l'aco vidé puis du
choc économique qu'elle a provoqués a
balayé par la contestation qui est quand
même de la contestation
oui basque haineux en ce qui concerne la
réforme des retraites
elle sortait d'un côté bien sûr à la
contestation dans la rue
elle s'est heurtée aussi au fait que les
partenaires sociaux en particulier les
syndicats
au bout d'un certain moment refusé de
négocier le premier ministre de l'époque
edouard philippe voulait ajouter à la
réforme structurelle que portait macro
voulais rajouter le report de l'âge
ouvrant le droit à la retraite
grosso modo de 62 à 64 ans est d'à côté
ça bloquait complètement les syndicats
même la cfdt et de l'autre c'est devenu
complètement hors sujet avec la forte
hausse du chômage que on a connu du feu
du fait de la crise de l'aco vide donc
naturellement le ce projet de réforme
des retraites est aujourd'hui disons
suspendu alors c'est vrai que bruno le
maire il souhaite comme à mener cette
réforme atteint pour diminuer la dépense
publique la dette a explosé elle devra
dépasser les 110 7 % du pib à cette
année est ce qu elle doit être
poursuivie cette réforme des retraites
la particularité de la réforme des
retraites telle qu'elle était engagée
c'est que de toute façon elle ne l'avait
défait que en 2037 jusqu'à 2037
grosso modo les personnes les retraités
partait avec les règles de à l'ancien
système dont au mieux ce n'aurait pas
été avant 2037 que effectivement il
aurait pu y avoir des effets favorables
mais de toute façon ces effets étaient
extrêmement progressif puisque la
retraite puisque la réforme
rentré en activité de façon extrêmement
lente et donc on peut pas compter sur
une réforme aussi progressifs pour avoir
un impact important sur les dépenses
publiques à la seule manière qu'on
aurait pu imaginer pour effectivement
avoir un impact sur les dépenses
publiques ce n'était pas la grande
réforme structurelle que portait macron
c'était tout simplement comme les
méthodes classiques d'un côté d indexer
les retraites et de l'autre dire aux
gens bien vous partez pas 62 vous partez
à 64 ans mais voyez maintenant si on dit
en partance passant de mai à 64 ans mais
sur le marché par an on a besoin grosso
modo d'environ 1,6 million d'emplois
supplémentaires alors que c'est pas du
tout aujourd'hui la priorité de garder
les vieux au travail alors que la
priorité c'est de trouver de l'emploi
pour les jeunes donc que la réforme la
réforme edouard philippe est
complètement hors sujet et la réforme
macro
c'est beaucoup trop lent pour avoir en
effet il faut rappeler aussi que le
gouvernement était englué dans des
négociations sectorielles avec les
régimes autonome les avocats les
médecins les kinésithérapeutes les
pharmaciens qui chacun avaient leurs
problèmes et de l'autre côté avec les
enseignants qu'il fallait indemnisés de
la réforme qui aurait fait me fait
baisser très fortement le niveau de leur
retraite
donc tout ça est un dossier extrêmement
compliqué que visiblement le
gouvernement n'a pas la capacité à gérer
aujourd'hui alors que déjà il a d'autres
problèmes que se soient fait vacciner
tout le monde et surtout relancer
l'économie mais alors pas vous en parler
à juste titre aussi de cette crise
sanitaire il va falloir donc revoir les
priorités il ya une réforme aussi
importante à la réforme de la santé
celle ci est ce qu'elle peut être mise
de côté
non la réforme de la santé
bien sûr ne peut pas être mise de côté
il va falloir un membre donné que le
gouvernement dise clairement on change
de direction
on arrête la stratégie consistant à dire
il faut diminuer les lits d'hôpitaux
il faut réduire les dépenses de santé et
on va être obligés de prolonger
d'accentuer le ségur de la santé c'est à
dire augmenter les salaires des
infirmières des aides soignantes des
médecins hospitaliers pour que le métier
deviennent plus attractifs on a été
obligés d'augmenter le nombre de lits
parce que dans les années à venir on
sera toujours sous la menace de deux
pandémies
donc il va falloir dépenser plus pour la
santé
il faudra repenser aussi l'organisation
du système on voit très bien que le le
partage des tâches entre l'hôpital et la
médecine libérale n'est pas satisfaisant
a actuellement donc il faut le repenser
il faut donner plus de poids aux centres
de santé aux au dispensaire
il faut aussi avoir beaucoup moins
d'administratifs dans les hôpitaux et de
donner beaucoup plus de poids de pouvoir
aux médecins et au personnel soignant
tout ça c'est une réforme nécessaire
c'est pas la réforme que envisageait
macron qui était surtout une réforme
d'économies budgétaires
il ya une réforme en tout cas importante
enfin plutôt une lutte importante pour
réveiller le maquereau c'est la lutte
pour le climat il souhaite donc
l'inscrire dans la constitution
c'est quand même pour le coup un combat
qui est en adéquation avec les
aspirations des français alors que l' on
l'a appris que 2020 été l'année la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée en france oui
on a on a un problème clair c'est que
d'un côté bien sûr les gens sont quand
on les interroge effectivement sont pour
des mesures plus contre le changement
climatique mais ensuite il va falloir
mettre sans musique est naturellement ça
va a heurté un certain nombre de
personnes on voit très bien
il faut taxer le carbone et on a vu que
la taxe carbone c'était très difficile à
mettre en oeuvre il faut décourager le
véhicule individuel il faut taxer
lourdement les véhicules les plus lourds
les plus polluants
il va falloir développer massivement la
rénovation urbaine c'est des dossiers
c'est des dossiers importants
c'est des dossiers qui peuvent créer de
l'emploi mais en même temps c'est des
dossiers qui vont se heurter à aux
impôts qui vont frapper en quelques
sortes le mode de vie d'un certain
nombre de personnes a il faut que les
gens perdent l'habitude de prendre leur
voiture et utilise des transports en
commun ce qui nécessite bien sûr que on
développe les transports en commun mais
qui nécessite aussi des modifications de
modes de vie sains et la rénovation des
logements
il va falloir qu'un certain nombre de
propriétaires payent pour cette
rénovation de logements donc c'est un
effectivement il va falloir convaincre
la population que oui ça doit être
inscrit dans la constitution oui c'est
un enjeu important mais en même temps sa
mue en cause d'une certaine façon notre
mode de vie d' il va falloir être
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins gaspilleur
si on peut dire il va falloir métro m
en cause certaines pratiques qui peuvent
être très agréable mais qui sont
polluantes ou qui consomment beaucoup
d'énergie et il faut que les français se
préparent à une société
disons plus sobre est nécessaire compte
tenu des contraintes écologiques
merci beaucoup henri sterdyniak
économiste à l'ofce e membre des
économistes intéressant